l'ordre du jour appelle la question
orale de monsieur gérard bailly
transmise et monsieur me chargé des
transports de la mer et de la pêche
parole
ouais mais c'est président mainini chers
collègues je souhaitais attiré
l'attention de monsieur le ministre mais
aussi du gouvernement sur des
conséquences dommageables cora sur le
monde de l'élevage en termes de charge
supplémentaire d'une part la mise en
place de la taxe carbone pour les
transport d'aliments du bétail
d'approvisionnement mais sur des
exploitations agricoles mais aussi pour
transport de l'ensemble des produits y
compris comment de ces exploitations et
d'autre part la mesure consistera à
mentionner des équivalents carbone des
produits et de leur emballage
et auxquels devront s'ajouter puisque
c'est l'actualité de ce jour d
augmentation significative du prix de
l'énergie électrique nécessaire et
combien importante dans des
exploitations d'élevage
le ministre de l'agriculture et d'autres
membres du gouvernement se sont exprimés
lors du dernier salon de l'agriculture
sur les grandes difficultés que
traversent actuellement les éleveurs
tout comme les responsables agricoles
des différentes filières ovines bovines
porcines et avicoles
les chiffres parlent d'eux mêmes
puisqu'on constate la diminution
significative de ses productions voire
même catastrophique en qui concerne les
production ovine chaque jour la france
doit recouvrir à plus en plus à des
importations de production de viande de
volaille au mont seconde pays qui n'ont
pas les mêmes garanties sanitaires alors
qu elle a d'immenses espaces dédiés à
l'élevage et qui deviendront et qui
deviennent et tiendront des friches
principalement en montagne et ensuite on
sait les conséquences sur
l'environnement
avec
les avalanches ou les feux dans le sud
dans notre pays alors ce qui m'inquiète
c'est cette distorsion croissante de
concurrence et qui peut encore pénaliser
gravement les éleveurs français sur dans
le marché mondial cela accroît le manque
de rentabilité des éleveurs lorsque les
contraintes sociales déjà avec les
contraintes sociales
et avec obligation comme vous le savez
de présence qui sont pour les éleveurs
bien réel sur leur exploitation
l'augmentation importante des matières
premières céréales aggrave encore la
situation
devant ce constat nombre d'éleveurs
cesse leur production car il quand ils
le peuvent ils retournent les prairies
pour produire des céréales c'est
pourquoi ajouter des charges nouvelles à
une filière déjà en grande difficulté ma
paraît pas réaliste
ces évolutions sont graves et pourraient
bien conduire à terme à la disparition
progressive de l'élevage dans notre pays
si rien n'est fait mardi dernier ici
même lors du débat sur la réforme de la
pac au sénat tous les intervenants sur
tous les bancs sont soulignés la
situation dramatique et de désespoir des
éleveurs
alors monsieur le ministre je vous
interroge en temps le gouvernement
envisagez vous réellement de mettre en
place et deux dispositions qui ne
pourront que contribuer à alourdir
encore les charges financières des
éleveurs est donc mettre en péril un peu
plus encore leur existence
ne faudrait-il pas mieux mettre en place
d'urgence une politique de relance pour
cette filière qui malheureusement dans
notre pays est en fort déclin je vous
remercie simo chaque collègue la parole
et à monsieur philippe martin ministre
de l'écologie développement durable
d'énergie monsieur le sénateur
venant d'un département où l'élevage à
quelque importance le gers je connais
bien la situation dramatique je l' ai vu
se dégrader au cours de ces dix
dernières années où les éleveurs
laitiers ont quasiment disparu de mon
département je vous prie d'abord de bien
vouloir excuser frédéric cuvillier qui
devait répondre à votre question et qui
m'a demandé de le faire en son nom
le dispositif d'affichage
environnemental des produits et des
emballages en cours d'élaboration est
une application des articles 54 de la
loi du 3 août 2009 de programmation
relative à la mise en oeuvre du grenelle
de l'environnement et de l'article 228
de la loi du 12 juillet 2010 portant
engagement national pour l'environnement
ainsi une expérimentation nationale a
été menée entre le 1er juillet 2011 et
le 1er juillet 2012 le bilan de
l'expérimentation qui devraient être
transmis prochainement par le
gouvernement au parlement
sera accompagné de rapports sur les
retours d'expérience des acteurs un
premier retour d'expérience a été fait à
l'occasion du forum entreprises le 18
février 2013 plusieurs obstacles
techniques ont été soulevées de
standardisation de l'affichage comme des
référentiels il convient de définir les
modalités adaptées pour chaque secteur
en veillant à respecter l'objectif d'une
information claire et lisible du
consommateur s'agissant de l'éco taxe
poids lourds qui s'applique à tous les
véhicules de transport de marchandises
de trois tonnes 5 y compris aux
transporteurs étrangers elle entrera en
vigueur dès le 1er octobre prochain
proportionnelle aux kilomètres parcourus
sur le réseau soumis à l'écotaxe cette
première fiscalité écologique sera
directement liée à l'intensité des
parcours sur le réseau taxable les
échanges de proximité sont donc
favorisés
ce qui ne peut manquer de renforcer
l'attractivité des produits locaux et va
dans le sens de l'aide aux filières
agroalimentaires françaises ainsi les
flux d'importation sont
proportionnellement plus concernés par
la tarification routière péages
autoroutiers et écotaxe confondues par
ailleurs le choix du réseau taxable a
été fait dans un souci de concentrer la
tarification sur les axes principaux et
non sur le tissu local irriguées par les
voies secondaires les 15000 km de réseau
soumis à l'éco taxe représente moins de
1% du réseau routier français total le
réseau local concerné lui même limité à
5000 km ne représente que 1,3 pour cent
des 372 1000 km de réseau départemental
il est prévu qu'un rapport qui évalue
l'impact de l'écotaxe sur les
différentes filières soient transmis au
parlement d'ici le 31 décembre 2014 et
puisque vous évoquez les augmentations
de tarifs de l'électricité qui ont été
annoncées effectivement par moi-même
hier soir je dois dire que c'est le
précédent gouvernement n'avait pas joué
la politique de fuite en avant refusant
d'évaluer bien les coûts éventuels de
l'électricité dans d'autres pays nous ne
serions pas obligé de faire cette
augmentation qui est limité parce que
nous voulons veiller à ce que le pouvoir
d'achat des ménages et notamment des
plus fragiles ceux qui pourront avoir
accès aux tarifs sociaux de
l'électricité puisse être préservé merci
monsieur bailly monsieur bayer voulait
répondre monsieur le ministre
oui geminis merci de votre réponse mais
mon grand souci mais je crois que
celui-ci de beaucoup d'élus et je crois
que venant de départements que vous
venez de citer vous avez pu le constater
aussi cette diminution de l'élevage
président du groupe d'études de
l'élevage ici au sénat comprendrait bien
que quand je vois diminuer nos effectifs
de 20 d'une façon significative presque
50% 20 ans ces bobines également
diminution et refaire recours aux
importations vous comprendrez bien que
ans inquiète et jusqu'à maintenant les
agriculteurs ont toujours eue face à la
grande distribution vous le savez
monsieur 2010 beaucoup de difficultés à
répercuter l'augmentation de leurs
charges alors c'est vrai que me dit
certain nombre certain nombre est
atténuée parce que ce sera plus sûr des
autres itinéraires que seront pris cet
axe ses taxes mais croyait bien quand
même que je suis ce sera intéressant de
suivre cela de près et qu'il y ait
vraiment une motivation aussi des
pouvoirs publics du gouvernement pour
que l'augmentation dont vont subir les
éleveurs principalement du fait de ces
trois dispositifs dont le prix d'énergie
dont je rappelle la nausée dans nos
fermes d'élevage et plus
particulièrement montaigne sur les
secteurs davos et nous avons de séchage
en grange et qui nécessite beaucoup
d'énergie électrique que les charges
aussi vont augmenter donc pourquoi pas
mais comment les répercuter sur les prix
de vente c'est là mon souci mme shea
ministre et j'ose espérer je crois que
cet après midi à notre commission
rencontre le ministre annonce ce sera
aussi l'occasion de l'évoquer parce
qu'on peut pas faire en sorte de peser
davantage sur les éleveurs qui vous le
savez monsieur demi nue sans difficulté